in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kyle
and Brooke are with us hey guys how are
ya hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve welcome welcome we're y'all from
Cedar Rapids Iowa well good to have you
it's a bit of a haul to Nashville yeah
nine hours with two small children which
equates you get double 5/8 18 hours yeah
you get at least double points yeah Wow
I'm eight well two small children might
be four extra I don't know but anyway
very cool guys so how much debt have you
paid off so we paid off two hundred and
seventy two thousand dollars we
originally had a five-year plan and we
ended up doing it in 37 months way to go
and your range of income during that 37
months we started about 135 and we've
moved up to about 175 or a little bit
more based on bonuses and stuff
you're kicking it what do you guys do
for a living so I work in real estate
I'm an asset manager for a commercial
real estate portfolio mm-hmm and I'm an
Operations Manager and actually got two
years ago this journey that we've been
on kind of inspired me to go out and
develop a second career as well as an
investment advisor I'm trying to help
other people through the on this process
Wow very cool well you guys are dragging
the money home way to go proud of you
very well done so two hundred and
seventy two thousand dollars what was
that on it was about fourteen thousand
was a vehicle loan and about 250 mm or
was the house you paid off your house
yes sure weird yes yeah you're so weird
it's a great feeling that is awesome are
you guys for 33 ah it's paid for what's
this house worth 350 or so 360
awesomeness Wow feel at 33 years old
awesome
it's great it's ours no one can take it
from us yeah top of the world man that's
amazing yeah it feels great very very
neat man that's amazing congratulations
you that that's impressive you're heroes
man this is cool
proud of you so how do you do that tell
people they how you 33 years old and pay
off your house in 37 months we were
always what we felt fairly responsible
with our money might actually introduced
to you about maybe about four years ago
knocks has been
since we paid off the debt from a
co-worker and we were carpooling and
he's like have you heard of this guy on
the radio and you might like it he'd be
the kind of guy you'd want to raise your
kids if you know you weren't around and
so we started listening to you on AM
radio in Iowa and then I downloaded your
iHeartRadio app and then from there we
started listening to the program pretty
much every night and after hearing about
the Total Money Makeover book I borrowed
the book from my older brother and read
it in a day I think I ran into the
kitchen after that and I said Brooke we
need to write a check for $14,000
tomorrow pay off the car and then we're
gonna get the house done in about five
years so I may not have approached it
you know the best guessing and Brooke
said say what were you drinking back
there because you know a lot of people
say you know automobile loans are so
cheap you know it's only a 1% why would
I pay that on my 0% interest why would I
pay that off but you know as you look at
that it's it's yours no one can ever
take it anything can happen you know
with losing a job a health and you
didn't have that financial freedom now
we don't have the risk I remember when I
was reading the book Reagan would have
been our oldest who's six now she would
have been about two and a half and she's
playing with her nine-month-old sister
who's now four and I remember reading
this paragraph in the book you talk
about you know changing your family tree
and leaving a legacy and I knew with the
incomes that we made and how diligent
we'd already been throughout our lives
of just saving money that if we got on
this program in it and it looked like it
would work there it made sense I knew
that we could really change our family
tree and just make an absolute
difference in not only our immediate
family but nieces and nephews in
community and in our church and it's
been phenomenal man that's awesome
that's awesome Brooke as a portfolio
manager you just did a great job of
describing risk you really did I mean
the debt adds risk and in the world that
you were trained in and I was trained in
we're not trained about I'm putting math
to risk very often right we have this
vague sense that it's out there but we
don't we don't and in the real estate
world we don't always attribute the
leverage the risk that goes with
leverage to it and on the consumer side
we sure don't with a 1% car loan and
that kind of junk so you're very very
wise to do that and you know it's true
when you get it paid off because
something's the switch flips down inside
doesn't it
never slept better yeah this is it
financial piece two words that don't go
together like airline service yeah you
know that kind of thing so way to go you
guys very very well done
I'm very proud of you that's awesomeness
what was the hardest part of this um I
hadn't personally for the hardest part
for me was the travel you know I like to
travel especially in the cold
Iowa winters and you know we really put
that on hold we we didn't take any big
trips we just took little trips around
the Midwest and really focused on the
biggest one was this past year the Iowa
Hawkeye so into Pasadena Rose Bay yeah I
was unable to travel with my parents my
sisters and other family members because
we were four months away and we were so
close it just it wasn't worth a little
hiccup in the road to deter us so so not
be able to travel but hopefully we'll be
able to try and pick that up now as the
future I got to tell you aut fan was
cheering for you because your
quarterbacks from here that's right ah
yeah from right here in our community on
those dad real well is a songwriter in
the area yeah that game against the
Stanford went about as well as than one
before against your volunteers but
you've had a couple good seasons
absolutely proud of them young man's a
sharp young man that I guess he's
graduated now and going on but Beathard
but ya know he's back cuz he got one
more you know more year okay oh I didn't
know that really his brothers got a hit
on the country radio right now I heard
it so uh fun stuff well way to go you
guys congratulations very very very well
done proud of you
alright it's Kyle and Brooke Reagan and
Riley
how old are Reagan and Riley Reagan is
six and Riley is four all right have
they been practicing for 18 hours for
about three years every night we clap
for everyone else oh now you get to do
it regular Riley no Reagan Riley
everybody's gonna rate your debt-free
screen so you got to really go for it I
mean just as loud I want you to be so
loud that you shake the windows in our
building okay so here we go this is what
the sound of a family tree being changed
sounds like right here and it's cute too
so those of you watching on television
Kyle and Brooke and Reagan and Riley two
hundred and seventy two thousand dollars
paid off that's their house and
everything in 37 months count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
I love it absolutely fabulous well done
you guys man and hold on we're going to
give you a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book which is the next step a
signed copy of that because now it's
time for you to move the rest of the way
into wealth building you don't have a
house or anything to pay off you got
nothing to do with this wonderful income
but give live and invest give live and
invest and kick that into overdrive of
Christmas retire inspired number one
best-selling book will help you do that
so hold on we'll give you a copy of it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind